hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the intractable problems that was
faced by the Roman Republic through much
of its existence and especially towards
the end of its days which Cicero the
writer of on duties took part in was the
clash between not just personalities but
you can say factions parts of the
Republic were being turned against other
parts it's not simply that each you know
great individual like Caesar or Pompey
had their soldiers that were fighting
against each other each of them
represents parts of the body politic
turned against each other and this was
not a you know new problem it was
something that had been faced and
discussed quite a bit with in ancient
Greece even within the city-states think
about Athens itself which Cicero
mentions here and it was a problem
continuing through it's one that that we
see even raising its head so frequently
in our own times where the the common
good and the sense of community gets
lost and we get factionalized or you
know to use a word that we invoke much
more often today things become very
partisan things get separated out along
partisan lines
so what Cicero has to say here is very
relevant and he's interested in this in
terms of the virtue of courage so he
talks about it in that portion of book
one of on duties why why is he so
interested in encourage and great-souled
miss and and then looking at at factions
and elections and all these sorts of
matters
well because politics tends to draw in
individuals who are high-spirited who
are great-souled who are courageous
people who are also ambitious and the
ancient understanding of ambition was
not just that you're going to you know
make
million dollars or you know you've got
the drive to start your own business
it's that you want honor you want other
people to look at you as being an
important person you want them to
include you in their decision making you
want to be a big shot we could say all
right
that's what to be ambitious really is
about if you want to make a million
bucks you want to make a million bucks
because you think that means that you
thereby become someone all right if you
want to be in the fashion magazines
that's because you think as opposed to
the person who wants the million bucks
that being in the fashion magazines
being something if you're on YouTube and
you want to have a million subscribers
that's ambitiousness as well and each of
them has to do with a kind of perceived
power and fame politics is a natural
place for this to to occur because
people do bestow honors as a matter of
fact the very word for offices in
ancient Greek Tim a means honor as well
and so you know this carries through
into the Roman context and and it
carries through I think even down to our
own time where we tend to have sort of
worshipful attitude towards the
politicians who we all we like so it
does draw in people who if they're not
necessarily courageous at least have a
facsimile of courage which can be quite
dangerous and here Cicero actually
invokes Plato interestingly enough he
says those who propose to take charge of
the affairs of government should not
fail to remember to plato's rules first
to keep the good of the people so
clearly in view that regardless of their
own interests they'll make every action
conform that second to care for the
welfare of the whole body politic and he
says if we don't have this what do we
see as he calls it bitter strife right
discordia a literally one's heart being
out of accordance with another person's
heart and that's how societies break
down or become prey to
other societies which will then invade
them and colonize or take them over so
this is a big problem when we focus or
when people focus in general on their
own individual good or on the good of
just a part of the society or culture or
community as opposed to the common good
then we're going to have factions arise
now why would that be the case well in
some respect it's kind of self-defense
if I know that you are a rival
politician and you do not have my best
interests at heart because you only care
about your class or your group or your
you know allies or something like that
then I not only shouldn't vote for you
and I should stay away from you I should
probably run against you or find
somebody else who will support my
interests and you know as I do that your
attitudes harden my attitudes harden the
other people may form a third faction
because they're like well we're not
being represented by any of these two
jokers neither of them seems to care
about us let's get our own candidate out
there and this can happen through you
know military who's this can happen
through class warfare or you know
struggles between other groups within
the Roman Republic it took place in part
through elections because the Romans had
this set of offices that you had to sort
of make your way through in order to
eventually exercise power at the highest
level it was called the cursus honorum
the you could say the path of offices
the paths of honors and cicero saw this
firsthand and and so did his rivals they
all had to make their way up through the
cursus as did people before them there
are ways to try to jump around it and
many people use that as an opportunity
just to enrich
themselves or to gather their own
political power sometimes they used it
as a way to develop a power base as
Caesar did with his rulership over Gaul
which the ending of which is what
brought him to cross the Rubicon right
so this is a very important point he
says those who care for the interests of
a part of the citizens and neglect
another part introduced into the civil
service a dangerous element dissension
that is discord ium and parties strife
seditions is is the word that we get
from that so this is incredibly
important now he talks about
electioneering in particular the word
that we're translating as electioneering
is content Co which of course you know
the English contention contentiousness
is is what we get from that and it's
it's not just that but it's also the you
could say desire for for doing that he
says the ambit co-owner Durham Content
Co so it's it's the desire the ambition
and also the striving the the contending
with others for offices and he gives us
some counsel here that are not actually
going to be observed by it by most
people in politics but this is what he
thinks would be required if you're going
to exercise genuine courage within the
political sphere which should lead to
less faction he says that we should view
our rivals not as enemies but as fellow
citizens he says here we go we should
regard only those as adversaries who
take up arms against the state not those
who strive to have the government
administered according to their
convictions so here in the United States
we have two main parties if you were
following this you would not look and
you were Republican you would not look
at your Democratic rival as your enemy
as you know this terrible person who you
need to demonize and if they win you
would in some way try to cooperate with
them like
wise if you're the Democrat and the
Republican wins you could ask yourself
has that been the case over the last
several decades between these two
parties when the answer of course would
be no he gives you an example of several
different characters from Roman history
and and we see that you could come up
with many other examples of people who
did not do that who said if you're not
with us you're against us within the
same Society
he also counsels a you might say control
over one's effects in relation to one's
opponents so he talks a lot here about
anger because anger is that back then
just as much as it is now a very
important emotion to understand for
politics he says we must not listen to
those who think that one should indulge
in violent anger against one's political
enemies and imagine that is the attitude
of a great spirited brave person he says
nothing is more commendable nothing more
becoming than courage and forbearance
genuine courage does not mean losing
your mind and shouting and railing
against your terrible opponents and the
awful things that they've done and how
bad everything is going to get we might
think about the contemporary
mobilisation of anger by so many
political parties and operatives and
organizations in our own time and
whether that would actually fit what
what Cicero was talking about instead he
counsels what we translate here as
affability which is a beautiful name
isn't it
he says we must school ourselves in
affability and what is called mental
poise that is altitude oh ah nummy and
the F ability is [ __ ] you'll eat us
right an ability to reach out to the
other person to treat them civilly to to
treat them as if they're another human
being belonging to your society your
Commonwealth he says to do this even
the other person is not he says if we're
irritated when people intrude upon us
that's unseasonable hours or make
unreasonable requests we will develop a
sour churlish temper prejudicial to
ourselves and offensive to others and he
says the only other condition on this is
that strictness may be exercised for the
good of the state but if if we're going
to have to punish people or resist them
we don't need as he says to be insulting
about this we don't need to tear them
down we don't need to you know to use
one common expression for every time
somebody hits you hit them back ten
times that would be foolishness the
opposite of wisdom according to the
Stoics and we can see that this this
played itself out within the Roman
Republic if you look at you know the
historical examples of Marius and sulla
and and the civil disorders at that time
or you look at you know the the first
triumph or it or the second triumph or
it you will see these these sorts of
forces playing themselves out the last
thing that I'll talk about is Cicero
talks about the need to manage success
well the need to not exploit one's good
fortune as he says it tells us when
fortune smiles in the stream of life
flows according to our wishes which is
not often the case in politics let us
avoid all arrogance haughtiness and
pride it's as much he says a sign of
weakness to give way to one's feelings
in success as it is in adversity so when
we're actually on top in this crazy game
of politics don't exploit it don't try
to drive everybody else out
don't try to rub everybody's noses in it
and don't try to make yourself more
important than you are he gives the
example of philip of macedon who we
don't really hear that much about we
hear more about his famous son and
Cicero says Alexander was actually a
train wreck Philip was the better King
even though he didn't conquer so much of
Asia
he says the greater our prosperity we
have to be more and more careful we have
to seek the counsel of friends and we
have to think about who's giving us
advice don't listen to flatterers don't
listen to people who are just trying to
get you to you know do their thing you
have to be very careful in it he says
it's easy to deceive ourselves we come
to think ourselves duly entitled to
praise and perhaps we're not and so he
says you know when people can be puffed
up with conceit and expose themselves to
ignominy Kuehl by committing the most
egregious blunders when they actually
have been successful so to bring it to a
close you know we ought to be thinking
about the common good it's very
important when we're carrying out
contention with others about who is
going to rule that we observe certain
limits and we think about you know the
greater good in that case and then if we
do succeed don't let it get to our heads
this is what Cicero thinks will help to
prevent social breakdown and in his view
it's precisely the failure of people who
were highly placed in politics to be
virtuous in this way that led to the
great disorders that destroyed the Roman
Republic
you